[Musica]
[Applauso]
Luigi ha 60 anni è troppo giovane per
andare in pensione ma è anche troppo
vecchio per un nuovo lavoro Luigi è
malato ha l'asbestosi una malattia
cronica che colpisce polmoni quando si
respirano per troppo tempo le fibre di
amianto e Luigi Purtroppo le Respirate
per ben 35 anni Per uno strano inghippo
burocratico però non riesce ad accedere
alla pensione a cui avrebbe diritto e
per questo è costretto a vivere in un
camper senza elettricità senza acqua
corrente e per mangiare dipende da il
cibo che gli dà la Caritas Questa è
l'istantanea che avrei potuto scattare
di Luigi quando l'ho conosciuto e ho
deciso di raccontare la sua storia siamo
andati a incontrarlo abbiamo passato un
po' di tempo con lui G abbiamo abamo
fatto vedere a tutti Come viveva E per
quale assurda situazione poi ovviamente
siamo andati da chi di dovere e
indovinate un po' nel giro di un paio di
settimane a Luigi è arrivata la pensione
la sua situazione si era sbloccata ci
siamo sentiti abbiamo fatto una
videochiamata e gli ho chiesto Luigi Ma
allora adesso qual è la prima cosa che
farai e lui con gli occhi che
sorridevano mi ha detto Alice vorrei per
una volta fare una cena vera Voglio
andare al ristorante con i soldi della
pensione quello è stato il momento in
cui ho capito che il mio lavoro Se è
fatto bene ha davvero il potere di
cambiare le cose e di avere un impatto
sulla vita delle persone questo non
significa sempre trovare una soluzione
ma piantare dei piccoli semini creare
consapevolezza fare buona informazione e
poi piano piano spingere verso un
cambiamento pensate a quanto è
importante oggi parlare di ambiente
pensate a quanto è importante parlarne
in maniera precisa puntuale parlare di
crisi climatica Ecco questi sono temi
ambientali nel Nel senso vero della
parola ma non sono lontani dalla storia
di Luigi e vedremo perché hanno tutti un
qualcosa a che fare con la sostenibilità
e oggi vorrei portarvi in un viaggio con
me attraverso le storie che il
giornalismo racconta e vi vorrei
mostrare come quelle storie abbiano il
potere di cambiare le vite individuali
ma anche di plasmare il nostro futuro in
maniera più responsabile in maniera
sostenibile sostenibile è una parola che
usiamo molto spesso e letteralmente
deriva da sostenere tenere in alto
difendere proteggere conservare Ecco
Penso che un giornalismo sostenibile
debba fare proprio questo debba portare
in alto debba proteggere difendere debba
evidenziare quei temi umani che oggi
meritano tutta la nostra attenzione
Questa è la nostra missione più
importante parlavamo di crisi climatica
Ecco è così importante parlarne parlare
con le persone e far capire che quello
che noi oggi viviamo non è normale ma è
il frutto di una serie di stili di vita
di comportamenti sbagliati che abbiamo
avuto nel tempo e che hanno abusato
delle risorse del nostro pianeta e Oggi
più che mai è importante invertire la
rotta Siamo a Forte dei Marmi se
qualcuno di voi lo scorso anno più o
meno di questi tempi si trovava qua non
può che ricordare quella giornata
terribile in cui la Versilia e anche la
Liguria sono state spazzate via da
ondate di vento e di pioggia fortissime
il downburst come abbiamo imparato a
chiamarlo e non era la prima volta
perché in realtà già nel 2015 un evento
del genere si era abbattuto sulle nostre
zone erano arrivati 20 a 150 km/h Ecco
questa consapevolezza crescente che
abbiamo nei confronti delle tematiche
ambientali sappiamo quanto è importante
prenderci cura del nostro pianeta
salvaguardarlo Il che vuol dire anche
salvaguardare le nostre vite e la
qualità delle nostre vite ecco tutto
questo sicuramente deriva dalle
esperienze che facciamo ogni giorno
nella vita quotidiana viviamo il caldo
estremo subiamo piogge torrenziali Da un
momento all'altro però deriva anche da
una buona informazione dalle tante
inchieste giornalistiche che negli anni
ci hanno mostrato quanto è importante
parlare di ambiente quanto è importante
prendercene cura Ecco credo che un buon
giornalismo dovrebbe fare questo
dovrebbe identificare la causa di un
evento mettere insieme i pezzi aiutare a
ragionare e poi piano piano tracciare un
percorso verso un futuro più sostenibile
un futuro migliore io Non dimenticherò
mai il giorno in cui ho ricevuto la
segnalazione di Enzo un abitante di
Acerra in Campania in Piana Terra dei
Fuochi posso dire che la sua più che una
segnalazione era davvero un grido di
aiuto lui era esasperato perché come
ogni estate fuori dalla sua finestra
vedeva moltiplicarsi i roghi tossici che
avvelenano terra e aria e che ormai lo
sappiamo vengono appiccati per smaltire
abusivamente i rifiuti quello che ci
raccontava Enzo era una vera tragedia
però è anche una tragedia vecchia e noi
alle tragedie vecchie ci abituiamo il
pubblico perde interesse i giornalisti
ahimè non hanno più niente di nuovo da
raccontare e questo è il motivo per cui
non troverete la Terra dei Fuochi sui
giornali perché non è più una notizia
nel senso letterale del termine nuovo in
questo caso però abbiamo fatto una
scelta abbiamo deciso che la storia di
Enzo e tutte quelle storie di quelle
persone che poi abbiamo conosciuto
meritavano una voce proprio perché
nessuno gliela stava dando più abbiamo
scelto l'interesse pubblico invece del
pubblico così ci siamo trasferiti
Praticamente per due settimane nella
Terra dei Fuochi io insieme a Mauro
l'autore che ha curato con me questo
servizio e abbiamo dato la caccia ai
roghi insieme a Enzo e ai suoi amici
volontari pensate persone che si sono
costituite da sole per intercettare
questi roghi prima che divampo e che
esprimano al massimo il loro potere
letale Ci siamo rifugiati nelle vite di
sconosciuti che ci hanno letteralmente
aperto le porte di casa loro perché
quando c'è un rogo tossico grande L'aria
è respirabile nevica cenere e tu ti devi
nascondere Noi abbiamo vissuto la Terra
dei Fuochi che c'è esiste ancora oggi
anche se nei telegiornali probabilmente
non ne sentiamo parlare più e allora per
noi la notizia è diventata proprio
quella la Terra dei Fuochi continua a
bruciare nonostante Le inchieste
giornalistiche Le inchieste della
magistratura le denunce dei cittadini
poi ovviamente siamo andati a parlare
col ministro dell'ambiente che si
trovava in quei territori e gli abbiamo
fatto un sacco di domande perché quello
che ho imparato con l'esperienza è che
il nostro lavoro consiste nello
scegliere delle storie nel sottoporle a
un pubblico Ma poi anche a mostrare a
chi di dovere a chi può davvero cambiare
le cose che ci siamo che monitoriamo gli
sviluppi di quella storia che
monitoriamo le promesse fatte è quello
che chiamiamo il cane da guardia della
democrazia che siamo sinceri l'abbiamo
un pochino addomesticato perché ogni
tanto ci dimentichiamo di fare le
domande invece è importante che sia
bello sveglio questo cane Io non posso
dire che con quel servizio abbiamo
cambiato le cose però posso dire che
abbiamo sostenuto il tentativo di
resistere di tutte quelle persone enenso
i suoi amici volontari le mamme dei
bambini malati abbiamo raccolto la loro
lotta una lotta tenace e l'abbiamo
mostrata a tutti per quello che è in una
catastrofe quella della Terra dei Fuochi
che è una catastrofe sanitaria sociale
economica e anche politica ancora non
risolta e il pubblico tutto questo lo ha
capito Ci sono arrivate un sacco di
email che ci hanno detto continuate a
raccontare e credo che nel nostro
piccolo abbiamo un po' acceso una lucina
su una storia dimenticata in qualche
modo un po' accettata io ho imparato che
ogni cambiamento così con il racconto di
un'ingiustizia di qualcosa che non va Un
piccolo racconto e poi piano piano
insieme cercando di costruire qualcosa
di buono ovviamente giornalisti e
pubblico insieme perché vi assicuro che
noi da soli non bastiamo E questa cosa
l'ho capita in maniera compiuta lo
scorso anno quando mi sono imbattuta in
un'altra notizia del tutto diversa la
notizia di 218 milioni di mascherine
prodotte male inutilizzate sono le
mascherine che abbiamo prodotto nella
primissima Ondata del covid quando non
avevamo nulla da mettere però non le
abbiamo fatte bene quindi nessuno le ha
mai usate quelle mascherine ci sono
costate tanto €13.000 al mese solo per
lo stoccaggio vuol dire 2 milioni e
mezzo di euro così lo scorso anno il
generale figliuolo ha deciso di
disfarsene di bruciarle costo di questa
operazione altri €700 m000 quando ho
letto questa notizia Mi sono detta è mai
possibile che nel 2022 non ci sia
un'alternativa a bruciare delle
mascherine un qualcosa che è un
grandissimo spreco e ha anche un impatto
ambientale devastante e abbiamo scoperto
in realtà che un'alternativa c'è perché
al Politecnico di Torino si sono
inventati un modo per riciclare queste
mascherine che in teoria non sarebbero
riciclabili perché sono fatte di un
materiale non biodegradabile loro le
sminuzzano aggiungono degli additivi
particolari e creano una specie di filo
che grazie ha una stampante 3D può
essere trasformata in un qualunque
oggetto di plastica di uso quotidiano
quindi le mascherine Da rifiuto
diventano opportunità e questa cosa si
sta già facendo in tante parti del mondo
in Australia con le mascherine
costruiscono le strade è un progetto
pilota però hanno capito che se vengono
unite al calcestruzzo quell'alto è più
elastico è più stabile questa notizia
del riciclo ci è sembrata una cosa
ganzissimo e abbiamo detto facciamo un
servizio Anche perché poi abbiamo
scoperto che a Milano esiste un'azienda
che fa questo procedimento già su scala
industriale E quindi avrebbe anche
voluto acquistare le nostre mascherine
perché gli servono per lavorarle così
abbiamo messo tutto dentro un servizio
Anzi due e ovviamente abbiamo cercato di
F arrivare questa informazione ai piani
alti alla struttura
commissariale Purtroppo ci hanno
risposto che la procedura per
identificare L'azienda che poi avrebbe
smaltito quelle mascherine si era già
avviata l'azienda era già stata scelta e
quindi quelle mascherine sono state
bruciate ma c'è un Però per fortuna un
bel però perché dopo la messa in onda
del servizio l'azienda di cui vi parlavo
ci ha chiamato dicendo di essere stata
subissata di chiamate da parte di
aziende scuole enti pubblici che avevano
una marea di quelle mascher e purché non
venissero bruciate ma riciclate erano
disposte addirittura a regalarle le
persone quindi hanno visto quello che
raccontavamo questo spreco enorme e
hanno risposto hanno deciso che in
quella storia potevano fare la
differenza potevano fare qualcosa di
buono ed è così che
funziona perché noi senza la vostra
indignazione non andiamo da nessuna
parte soltanto se lavoriamo insieme con
passione con responsabilità con
convinzione ognuno facendo la sua parte
potremo costruire o perlomeno tentare di
costruire un futuro migliore per tutti
in un momento storico come questo dove
la verità spesso viene messa in
discussione credo sia nostro dovere come
giornalisti come lettori come cittadini
del mondo combattere per ciò che è buono
per ciò che è bello
per ciò che è vero la sostenibilità non
è soltanto un concetto ambientale è un
impegno verso l'umanità è un impegno che
comincia con ognuno di noi oggi e ogni
giorno
Grazie